welcome to the o2 messaging service
the person you are calling is unable to
take your call
please leave your message after the tone
hi angie it's julie just ringing to
check that you and bonnie are okay
give me a call on my mobile or text me
if you need anything and i'll give you a
call back
at skegness academy they have a list of
morning calls
and if a parent's phone rings out and
the child isn't engaging online
then it's an assignment for former
police officer andy hickenbottom
this tourist location on the eastern
edge of england has suffered badly from
the pandemic
the lights have been off and the
shutters down too long the school and
people like andy
want to make sure that their pupils
futures aren't another casualty to the
virus
andy is one of the trust's eight
education welfare officers in segness
his task is to get eyes on the children
in some cases just to make sure
they can access online learning we are
providing
the same amount of lessons per day now
in lockdown as we were if a
child was in school um but uh you know
it's
it's whether that child really wants to
engage with it and whether parents can
be bothered to do it as well good
morning bonnie
how are you fed up right
okay let's see if we can fix it anyway
all you have to do is click join
on that right hand side and then it
should take you straight into that
lesson okay
you may have to wait in a lobby to start
off with but then as soon as the
class starts you'll be invited in your
next lesson starts at 11 o'clock and
you've got science
okay good that's all right then apart
from the buttons
we don't like experiments bonnie tells
me lockdown has been a challenge
just get really really stressed and
stuff board and i want to go to school
and stuff but you can't
in one of my drawers i've got loads of
like stress boards and stuff
so obviously i go and play with them or
my friend or tablet whatever
that helps does it yeah
the local primary school hasn't been
able to get hold of parent of two
charlotte danskin
and for several minutes it looks like no
one's home
but then charlotte comes out with
daughters rihanna
and adele i've come around to make sure
that you two are okay number one
and number two mum i don't think school
has been able to contact you at all have
they
no no i've only just got my phone back
working brilliant okay
is it the same the same number oh yeah
it is yeah yeah yeah i've seen all the
emails from that but obviously i ain't
got the wifi at the moment
okay right we'll see if we can do
something about that did you see
one of your families died yeah nan
i'm so sorry brandon's in hospital all
right he's been there today
oh my word and then my other niece was
her mama
she passed away with it so it's not
going very well for us
no it's not it's been awful i understand
why you'd be frightened about taking
your kids to school
yeah i'd rather keep them at home and
they've learned a lot to be fair
what do you think about not going to
school at the
it's moment i just love my school and i
can't go to school
oh i'm gonna find this so you're missing
it yeah
i am trying my best but obviously with
no wi-fi and that i i'll do my own stuff
for them
yeah so but we are going to get some
learning packs sent
home yeah so you don't have wi-fi no we
don't have a minute now
is that because it's expensive basically
yeah a lot of expenses i had it but
obviously i didn't pay it so obviously
yeah so single parent so it got cut off
basically
and what about feeding the kids i mean
is it it's no we feed the kids
absolutely fine obviously we get help
from the school from
like the vouchers and stuff like that
but yeah they get fed
wayne nori is chief executive of
greenwood academy's trust
so you feel there aren't there aren't
any kids in in your school at the moment
going hungry
i can't guarantee that and i would love
to sit here and say to you
not we're doing our very best at the
moment i think
um the community of skagness have been
fantastic but i think
they've been severely hit by tourism is
a huge
employer and if the summer was a very
difficult time for many of our families
like many resort towns skegness has a
transient community
and after florida it has the highest
density of caravans
in the world around a quarter of the
children who attend skegness academy
live in caravans and at this time of
year when the caravan parks close
they sometimes go missing from education
tell me about this
child then two children um both at my
primary schools and inga miles
um they uh they disappeared um
after a couple of days of no contact i
obviously did the home visit
found out that the caravan was actually
rented out to a to holiday makers
and they'd disappear without affording
the dress what can you do to try and
track them down and we can report it to
where we have to report it to the county
council
and they can make follow-up enquiries
obviously if they're claiming benefits
they'll have to claim them to a new
address if they go on role as another
school
then we're notified straight away as
well um but in the meantime it's to try
and check with the caravan site owners
to see whether
they've left a forwarding address for
them and with neighbours
see if they know where they've gone to
as well would you say children missing
in education's become
more of a problem in the pandemic harder
to locate yes
and harder to make the inquiries as well
todd johnson is head master
of skegness academy children are not
signing into lessons that's flagged
immediately
and we have that separate team headed up
by
the e was um who are keeping an eye on
children and if we don't get a response
then we go we we go out and check
they're okay
because of the transient nature of their
accommodation i imagine though that some
of these kids maybe a small
portion of them but they do go off the
radar sadly
it's it's inevitable that um contact is
lost
never um through um
the school uh failing to update
information what often happens
is that situations and circumstances
happen
where families may move or be moved
and i am sure that letting the school
know
is not a first priority and i can
understand that
andy later finds out the family has
moved 100 miles away to barnsley
and so far only one of the children is
enrolled back at school
next stop jaden who needs a laptop right
you've got no problem accessing
microsoft teams
you know your your password and your
login excellent the year nine pupil
recently moved from a caravan park to
temporary accommodation in a bnb
how have you been coping with your
lessons because you've just got my
laptop so
what were you doing before that i've
been on my phone for a few
weeks trying to do it through word and
teams
doing your lessons and writing and stuff
on your phone as well yeah typing it
how was that
difficult as like writing lows and it's
like a small keyboard what's it like
living in a hater
difficult because like i don't have my
own space and like my desk is in the
living room so
the distractions with my mum watching tv
and my sister
it's been very hard trying to
concentrate on the teacher and what
they're trying to say
are you worried about your kind of
school development you're learning in
this piece
yeah what worries you um not
reaching my expected grades at the end
of gcses and not being able to get the
job our
dream of what do you want to do i want
to either become a teacher
or go down the medical route like i'm
like a doctor or something so you've got
good ambitions
but you think this could limit your
chances of being able to do that
in some lessons some teachers not able
to teach as much
because of the resources we're limited
to do you feel that this is damaging
your education
yes we've got six beers set up staff at
skegness academy want to make sure that
doesn't happen they've got covered
testing up and ready in the sports hall
the school's open to vulnerable kids and
those of key workers and some teachers
have even set up a voluntary salary
reduction scheme
so some of their wages go to helping the
children
our ambition for um every single child
who comes to this academy
has not changed the reason that my
teaching staff
and my support classroom support staff
are signing on to five lessons
as a minimum a day and delivering the
same content
is because we can't let what's happened
now define these young people in the
future
you're spending all day basically just
going around knocking on doors yes i am
yeah and what are you looking out for
i'm looking out for signs of domestic
abuse
uh i'm looking out for signs of
safeguarding concerns
uh which normally relate to neglect or
drug misuse
things like that is there a big drug
problem here
uh yeah quite large actually i think
we've got about six county lines gangs
currently
working in this area have you had it
incidents of the kids involved in that
from the school i'm afraid we'll javier
just before christmas we had one of our
students arrested
kovid is likely to cast a long shadow
over skegness
seaside towns already in slow decline
are now in economic freefall
a study by southampton university found
that skegness was in the top
five places most likely to be impacted
by the pandemic
and that is because it has a high
proportion of industries
that have been shut down by the lockdown
most notably
tourism on which so many families depend
while the local school is counting the
cost in increased demand
for free school meals and more children
at risk local businesses are worried
about the economic legacy they'll leave
their children
generations of sids families traded in
skegness scrap
since 1884 but when the shutters came
down
the bins were suddenly empty demand for
his business
plummeted we look after the trade waste
in the area all the you know the pubs
the venues the theaters the holiday
camps the amusement parks
the caravan parks we do everything i
mean we've had
financial crashes we've had snow hail
rain
and i'm sure my father and grandfather
had wars but we've never woke up on a
on a monday morning to absolutely
nothing and that's that's what happened
when kobe first hit
absolutely nothing no money no post
nothing it just
like turning the top off the tap could
be turned back on with the help of the
government's towns fund
aimed to kick-start regeneration
projects around the country
and skegness is hoping for a slice
coastal resorts in general and this area
particularly does have quite high levels
of deprivation
and that's why the time bids are going
to be really important we've got some
really encouraging
skills bids that go in there for a new
college that gives aspiration to
children
and if there is one positive that's come
out of this whole thing
is that people are now realizing just
how important the visitor economy and
the hospitality sector is
and there are real careers to be had
here you were a top three employer in
the whole country
and hopefully that will give aspirations
to children to grow
how to make sure lives don't end up on
the scrap heap
that's the goal of skegness academy and
people like
former police officer andy it's just
like what i used to do anyway which is
knocking on doors talking to people
i'm dealing with the same families that
i used to deal with you know
back in my yeah job yeah and now you're
dealing with their kids
and now we're dealing with the kids yeah
yeah and a lot of it a lot of the
education welfare side is is legal as
well do they ever go oh you're the cop
that arrested me
uh yeah i've heard that quite a few
times
yeah yeah that's tricky that's always
pleasant no
no but you're here to try and help their
kids how does that feel
for me it's superb because it's a
complete role reversal isn't it
you know before it was the more of the
punishment but now
i'm trying to do what i do just to
get the kids in education it's not just
about education though
you've seen over the last couple of days
that it's it's about their welfare
um it's about um whether they're
accessing the
free school meal vouchers you know
making sure that the home conditions are
good
you see my list of home visits yesterday
and today i'm probably doing about 20
per day
um so you know it's an awful lot of
children that aren't accessing their
education or not accessing school when
they've got that place
it's all linked the survival of skegness
the aspirations of its children
for some their best chances of achieving
them in these troubled times
is the lifeline being cast out from
their school
jason farrell sky news